NICK: I'm Nick, a design
advocate at Google.
JAMES: And I'm James, a
course developer at Udacity.
ROMAN: And I'm Roman, also
a design advocate at Google.
JAMES: If you haven't
figured out already,
this is a course
on Android design.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Clear,
compelling design
will help your
Android app stand out
in today's super
competitive market.
Take Udacity's Android design
course, built with Google,
to learn how to build beautiful,
consistent experiences
to delight your users.
Learn to sort your
dps from your pixels,
pick the right layouts
and navigation structures,
and style your app
to match your brand.
Learn the principles
and implementation
of material design to make your
Android apps clear, simple,
intuitive, and delightful.
Get started now.
Your users are waiting.
For more information,
visit udacity.com/google.